Why are you fighting against the new
moon? It's a night with a full moon, so if you search for your heart,
you're sure to do it.
I love you,
Claire
Onee-san too,
let's play with acidity again
If Momo Niigetsu-san is also respectful, it'll definitely be fun Even though
I told her that there are so many things I want to do with other people
Why did this happen to
me, too?  It's strange I had a lot of
right things, things
I wanted to do
, dreams for the future,
but now I don't care anymore.
The child's suffering,
his face distorted by unpleasant thoughts Rolling around in the swamp of despair It's
only then that I feel joy Only the sight of that child in pain heals me and
makes me feel
happy, my dear  they're broken in
mine
[music]